hi I'm Jennifer Lopez and I am here with
the cast of hustlers a lot of girls and
we're gonna take a BuzzFeed quiz to find
out what our stripper song is all right
you already know it don't say yeah okay
okay
[Music]
your friends would describe your energy
as charismatic chaotic sensual romantic
confident or Connie
hmm charisma I want to spare that baby
with being sensual but I think it's
confident would you pick it Lily I'm
definitely can be right there
I'm gonna pick romantic because I've
done some dumb things for dick if you
were a stripper you'd be best at
twerking wait hold anger adoption sorry
lap dancing stripping twerking all of it
- I am a stripper I want to say all of
it but I'm gonna say pole dancing it's
true
Carter you gonna put layers - oh I've
got a whole oh my girl let me see it
taking it all off someone stole your tip
so you confront that sneaky ho it's
bruised it on because you make it back
report them to the management clap
revenge still their tips I would never
let that happen so this crisis ends in
cross between confront that sneaky ho
and I would never let that happen
all right yeah it's sneaky huh like is
that I will never let that but you know
you might gonna get the man it didn't
happen is a
so I'm gonna say plot revenge Oh pick a
fierce red carpet look that speaks to
you this is one of Rihanna Nicki Minaj
at the MTV Awards and Beyonce she's a
title event Taylor Swift
ttours Lady Gaga you have us a man
Carrie at the corner and that's families
really these are like not their best
looks
they don't you speak to me per se per se
right lady I know I bet Lady Gaga yeah
Vanessa I was that one cuz you're gonna
do one I know it for a fact
alright I can't wait Ric I'm gonna go a
tree what's your best physical assets Oh
lips my butt my legs my eyes my chest
please my entire body please but really
I mean I really do Ramona does see my
eyes my whole body mother Freddie your
CV you see these booty lips
let's move my body my eyes i hypnotize
you with it my chest I bought them to up
it to time finally choose a male celeb
to give a seductive lap dance - OH drink
Charles Melton Idris Elba Shawn Mendes
Donald Glover or any Jonas Brother are
all three at the same time
Oh or all three Jonas Brothers at the
same time I really big Shawn Mendes and
just keep it safe and I get in any
trouble today Donald Glover I've got a
guy I'm Eric what I think it does what
you guys
then it won't come up you don't you tell
us which one you pick
I'll go ahead I mean this is with all
respect I know he's a married man but
interest Beyonce yes yes you got
coordination I messed over like I feel
like partition from Beyonce same thing I
would joke it's well you nasty thing you
heard her speaking and maidens were hip
nice bonds and she hurt me you're edgy
popped edgy sexy yeah yes this mirror
[ __ ]
[Music]